so
[Music]
i'll
open this hearing
of the review of dangerous affected or
insanity building policy
can i call for a chair please
i'd like to nominate philip redmond as
chair
and i'd like to see him please
right
uh well i'll put that motion
we have him over in a second are all in
favor
right thank you very much
do we have any apologies
i think we're all here so there won't be
any
conflicts of interest
are no conflicts of interest so
we'll move on to item four
wee bit of noise in the background for
those listening
uh who's going to speak to the
report
we've got
present
warren
gina maxwell and greg wilson
oh sorry i haven't introduced the panel
the panel today is myself philip redmond
on my left i have councillor kirsten
barnett
and on my right councillor wendy doody
thank you
we're no longer anonymous
uh is someone speaking
to the report at this point
warren
yes you can take that as red excuse me
please can you use your microphone as we
live streaming
sorry i didn't quite catch that
streaming so you need to use your
microphone right oh yes okay um can i
take it that this report has been read
yes you may okay
on that basis then can we have a
conversation about the content of the
report and any proposed amendments to
that report
right are you wanting to discuss
amendments
to the policy document at this point or
will that come under matter five
uh no
this is from the conversation we had
prior to this meeting regarding the
proposed amendments to the policy
right okay i see right okay
yeah do you want to talk about that now
under the report i think that would be
worthwhile because there's a bit of time
required for for this and then we
we move on to the hearing panel
deliberations
and matter five okay so okay we'll we'll
covered you want to speak
happy to have a conversation around that
because we've got greg who knows this
inside out
and um greg has had a chance to read the
commentary that's been delivered so far
for a conversation so
should we have that conversation now yes
thank you okay
so the first point uh was in the
introduction to one the meaning of
affected building there's an error in
that where it references section one
three two and in fact in fact what it
should have is section one two one a
right
okay thank you we would agree with that
yes
then we've got on the following page
under policy objective
uh the 1.3
the purpose of the policy
we've got
changed the words of the public
to people
we don't have any concerns about
changing it that's fine then we want to
add a bullet point
uh down the bottom which reads
earthquake prone buildings are managed
under the building earthquake prime
buildings amendment act 2016 and are
therefore excluded from this policy
now greg has a commentary regarding that
what made you change
the public to people what was your
reasoning behind that
the chairman came in and said i think we
should change this to people and i
thought well why not
i am hoping for a conversation on that
to be fair
i thought people reflected what we're
trying to achieve rather than just the
public
at the end of the day i'm not
too concerned either way i just want
people
i just want to ask them to get what you
mean by that so this is people um
in in a private capacity at around a
place or in a public
arena so if i can say that i had a
review of some of the other
policies that other councils have done
and they're very much gone along the way
of the chairperson's
wording if you like and actually
put people in there okay to encompass
the actual staff inside the building as
well not just the members of the public
going into the building so it becomes
very much a catch-all
thank you that's important
all right thanks lauren carry on
thank you now greg you put some
commentary on this just down here do you
want to speak to that so the other thing
was that we
mentioned the earthquake prone buildings
amendment act 2016
um
in relation to earthquake prone
buildings being managed under it
all those sections in the act from first
to july 2017 were actually put into the
building act
so they're all encompassed and the idea
was to have everything in
a one act if you like so that gave them
the power to do it so
the sections relating therefore to
earthquake prone building and all the
other ones now and they're encapsulated
in the building act
so that means we should be putting
under the building act sections
xxx whatever the sections are instead of
building earthquake-prone buildings in
women act 2016. yeah i should just
introduce building act 2004.
would we be able to reference the
specific sections
that cover earthquake-prone buildings
or is it or is it throughout the act
it's throughout the act but specifically
put in those sections which the
chairperson alluded to under the um
building earthquake prone amendments act
that put those all into the sections in
the building act now so it's from 133
onwards they're all um captured in there
now
are you suggesting then that we refer to
the building act rather than the
amendment
act i think now we're past that one july
2017 when they're adopted into this act
we probably just put the building act
okay so moving on down to item 4.1
assessment criteria so there's a
suggestion that we put an extra bullet
point down the bottoms which would say
the assessment will be made in the
corners section one two one and one two
three of the building act this will
include and this is the addition if the
building is an affected
do building have any
viewpoint on petting that or what what's
the definition of an affected building
great do you want to speak to that
you
it's actually um
by default
all related to a dangerous building
so off the top of my head and i'm going
to it now it's adjacent to
off
opposite
or connected to a dangerous building
thank you greg it's defined
on page one under number one
meaning of affected building we correct
the section
and i guess what we're really looking at
here is introducing the concept of an
affected building which wasn't in the
previous policy
it's a distinct change from what was in
and it's one of those meanings that have
come about from
the um
building amendment act on
earthquake-prone buildings so they've a
mechanical
category in there
just mr chair does the fact that that
hasn't been consulted on and may affect
additional owners
does that pose a problem for this area
i don't believe so we consulted on
dangerous affected and in sanitary
buildings
we're just looking for the policy to
reflect
essentially the wording of the building
act
and our obligations to have a policy
so that was one of the reasons council
barney won't actually have to go out for
public consultation was that extra
definition that we needed to i think
yeah
so
we're agreeing we will
put that additional bullet point in
okay and then we go down to 4.2 taking
action on dangerous affected and
sanitary buildings
so
the addition of an extra bullet point
which is uh we will consult with the
owner if any affected building
and decide on appropriate course of
action
now greg has got a commentary here
regarding section 133
ab do you want to speak to that quick
there was more or less along the line
that that came
into effect
on the first july 2007
17 when the building act amendment
came into being so there's a there's a
definition of meaning of earthquake
prone building
directly in the building act now rather
than the building amendment act
because one of the biggest changes was
and
for the councillors that were around
during the earthquake time
was that
the definition of an earthquake prone
building helped us resolve a lot of
issues um at that particular time
and then they amended the act and
um
an earthquake prone building could be
dangerous
it could no longer be dangerous because
it's under
so it's morphed into a different beast
um i suppose we're saying but
one of the things that
the
everyone was very concerned about was
providing
one document which encapsulated
everything to do
with buildings
and provided a pathway for councils and
building owners to work together
to resolve some difficulties and
one of the pleasing things was we've now
got one piece of legislation which makes
it easier to discuss with people and and
and to work towards
equitable solutions where we can
council barney sorry just a question
on this
in the situation there was a dangerous
book and sanitary building the affected
building owner was next door we consult
with them but they don't want to do
anything and they're going to ignore it
what would powers would we have
under this
particular
policy
i suppose
there's a distinction between
powers that we could use and actions
that we would
we would prefer to take
now
up until
we've had a very very very good
relationship with most building owners
and
it's normally if you provide in the form
of them a wee bit of assistance perhaps
an engineering brief or some sort of um
act that they can actually see that
there is an issue
um
we haven't really we haven't had one
that we've had to initiate legal
proceedings and go to court not saying
it won't happen in the future but there
are provisions and powers however you've
got to be very careful of those because
they come at quite a cost
so
one of the things that council can do is
actually take action to remove that
that danger
which means we we actually have to pay
for it
and then recover it through rates and
those sorts of things so
up to now we haven't had to to go down
that line but there is provision in the
act for us to do it and i see
um in some recent recent
legal papers that wellington city
council has done exactly the same thing
for one building owner who was reluctant
to engage with them and to work
something out so they've actually gone
and done some work
i'm just worried about the risk to
council
using on decide an appropriate course of
action is quite loose
but you're saying it's covered by the
building act that we still have remedy
under enforcing the building act
we can go down a path to remediate or or
to resolve the problem yes
however those sorts of things are a last
resort if we but there is a proficiency
there is provision to cover that thank
you
would i be correct greg and thinking
that the remedy is really against
with the owner of the dangerous building
and you may need to consult with the
owner of the affected building as to
whether they could continue to occupy
the building for example depending on
the risk
that's a very very very valid point and
that's exactly what has happened um
during the seismic events of 2011.
so
we as a council and council staff always
engage with the building owners anyway i
mean that's that's their first port of
call
and i think we've seen the benefit of
that with with what's happened in in the
urban centres around here so
before any action is taken there's
always meetings there's always
discussions there's always workshops and
often you'll find that the building
owner will come up with a solution
of his own
that we can actually work with and live
with
and by allowing that to happen
there's normally a
reasonable flow-on effect
so would i be correct in thinking that
the addition of that last bullet point
consult with the owners of affected
buildings
is really to cover in a mission possibly
that there was no mention of how you
enter
interacted with the affected building
owner yeah what i like very much about
that addition of that last sentence is
it actually qualifies what we actually
do now anyway
i will also just note here that we do
actually say notify the owner the
owner's agent but what we don't do is
say we will consult with the owner
because they are quite different you
know so i take the point i think it's
valid
i see we mean the subtlety difference of
the affected building here
these buildings that are affected in
that
can they still be
used for rental purposes or not because
this is a question that concerns me
okay
so if i may that
would be
the actual risk the not the perceived
risk but the actual risk so
you would any that we would have that we
would have a charter professional
structure and engineer as well as
council staff
um in discussion or consultation with
the owner of the dangerous building and
affected building would have a round
table so what would happen i'll give you
an example um perhaps
is the old camera shop rec night chemist
shop that used to be along the street
next door
so
they had robbies which was obviously
providing a huge concern so
we either had to shut the whole whole
tenancy and let's be honest
pretty pretty important um
in town so um we designed um petition
walls that would take
obviously if there's a bit of a rumble
and some stuff fell off it would
actually
be safe
and they lost a wee bit of the building
but they could con continue to use the
building so that's the sort of
things that you would look at doing
the last resort or the or the
or the least likely scenario is we would
shut the buildings down we would work at
some solution to make it work for them
maybe reduce space maybe those sorts of
things but we would look at doing that
that might also be putting a couple of
containers down the side to limit any
fallout so
thanks very much for that answer that's
very helpful in the hearing
okay so
turning over the page
under section
record keeping
so we're talking about any building
identified as dangerous or in cemetery
will have a note placed on it so the
question has been raised here is should
we
have a note on an affected building is
that what the intent of that was philip
yes i wondered in terms of the limb
the council is obliged to disclose any
information it knows about a particular
property
and whether you should be disclosing um
that a building is affected on the limb
as the question it wasn't covered
in um
in the record keeping section okay so
i've had a conversa initial conversation
with marie
um from customer service who looks after
this she said well that's an interesting
question so she is uh going to have a
look at the guimo act and also on the
list serve for the other councils and
ask how other councils manage this and
then come back to us with a um
suggestion but i think there's sense and
the issue has been raised here
because if i was buying a building that
was affected i didn't know
then i'd be pretty disappointed to think
that i will to find out i didn't know
yeah absolutely
so can we as a panel consider
including affected buildings
or
would your recommendation be to wait
until we hear back from marie in which
case we need to adjourn this hearing at
the end
if i could make a comment that
a dangerous and sanitary building notice
is recorded on the property file now
and then obviously if there's any
remedy to that because we've got none
outstanding at this stage
then there's another note recorded on
the limited opposition so it's just like
a
service request or in the senate we're
going to have that the situation has
been resolved
so i don't see it as any different from
having a dangerous or unsanitary
building notice it goes out on the limb
as it is now
so
just just to clarify that then if i'm
the owner of an affected building
is
that dangerous
notice for example
going to be referred to in milam
i don't think you actually could do that
i think you'd be if it was an effective
building it would be effective building
notice but it would have some
description on why it was affected
so you're saying that would be in the
lung that's your view yeah
right okay
but i was just that was something that i
um
when reading through it i just you know
just ringing but few alarm bells to me
for
the the property that's chosen adjacent
to it so and and
listening um to what you had to say if
they someone want to sell sell that and
it wasn't on the lung
then um
that is a problem but
how do you um really apart from doing
that effective on your limbs
how how else can that be
notified
do you want to answer that question okay
so with a dangerous or insanity or
affected building there's a notice
attached to the to the building so
you've got to attach to the building
for the affected building yeah that's
what i'm suggesting
it'll have an effective building notice
on it
but
sorry
um my suggestion is yes because
at the end of the day the public have
got a right or anyone
has a right to know by the same token
when you when that's rectified or
remedied
then that needs to go on there as well
and a note to say that
it's been lifted or been resolved the
other thing is is that
you know we're not
we're not hard to get hold of
i'm not
we would have discussions
i wouldn't visit if any of this and i've
had them before where people tried to
sell buildings so
if you straight out and straight up with
them and tell them what's there it
normally works out reasonably
reasonably well
but as far as i'm you know
unique they have a right to know
and i think we have a legal
responsibility
thank you that was the question
what's our legal obligation
so the amendment to record keeping would
be
any building identified as dangerous
affected
or unsanitary will have a note placed on
the property file yes the limb will note
that the building is dangerous
and sanitary or affected
so you're happy with
matt ryan
okay carry on sorry okay so just rolling
down the page we're down to an addition
uh of item 4.3 which regarding costs
isn't very clear in the policy
so the addition of something straight
out of the act which basically says
council may issue a notice under section
1242c
of the act required work to be carried
out
and um that work under the no decision
by councils
um is not completed or proceeded with
reasonable speed speed council may
invoke its powers under section 126 of
the act and apply to the district court
to gain authorization
to carry out work required in the notice
if council carries out the building work
it is entitled to recover costs
associated with that work from the
building act
sorry
from the building owner as set out in
section 1263 of the act
i think that makes it very clear
i think from what greg said earlier the
council has never actually had to do
that is that correct
yeah it's the worst case scenario isn't
it it does yeah that's right
but it is a you know should we say a
full back position
right
does gina or you wish to add anything
further
nothing from me philip
councillor barney yes
well this is slightly outside the scope
of what we're doing today there's
obviously been concerns in the
submission about earthquake-prone
buildings and i just wanted to quickly
ask
what has been done to communicate with
the public about our current status of
earthquake prone and likely to be
earthquake prone in the next 10 20 years
particularly in the private room
i'll have a stab at answering that
so every year i have to do a
document for the ministry of business
innovation employment
which lists um our earthquake-prone
buildings because if you go around the
street now you'll see more and more
parks attached to buildings so that
councils if you like
legal responsibility once we've
identified and gone through the process
on the buildings they give a rough
indication of the seismic capacity of
them and a date by which they have to be
remedied by
in the last um
report that i did for mb
i've said that
and the best of knowledge i've got we've
got no
unidentified
earthquake-prone buildings there's a
couple going through reassessments at
the moment
but they'll previously they've been
identified as likely earthquake prone
so
we're in
a pleasing
environment that we can actually report
on things like that
and the other thing is and you've
probably driven through from what end
past um
john branson just john bransgations has
two priority buildings down there and
you'll see one of them's
shrouded or wrapped up at the moment
that's being strengthened it's
um
building is it's got a live building
consent to strengthen as well
the old bnz building i think we're all
familiar with that i pursue obviously
got
jared hazel dean
and um
jed pearce owning that and that's that's
being done
so we're actually and we've got a
meeting with um
kai poi mill owners
um
in a couple of weeks time to actually
discuss where we're going with that
building as well so
we've only really got
one priority building outstanding or two
of them once once once those are sort of
rectified so the other seven and a half
year plan if you like or the timeline
um one would think well it looks like
we'll have all of them well and truly um
strengthened
to honest we'll put a wee bit of that in
there enshrined
well before the due date so that's
that's the ongoing if you like advantage
of working with people
right thank you greg that
explains
that
we bear in mind of course that
earthquake damaged buildings are outside
the scope of the policy and it's
specifically excluded
unless you've got anything further to
add i'll move the recommendation
a to
c under matter four
that's there a seconder
counselor
right well i think we've had a
discussion so i'm not proposing to say
anything further here we'll move on to
the hearing panel deliberations next
do you wish to speak counselor barney
yes it's it's interesting to note that
this in terms of submissions we really
didn't receive any on the matter itself
and um so i believe that the
the policy is obviously quite well
accepted and there's no uh red flags for
me and the fact that um i think it's
something that
isn't uh hasn't had a major effect in
our district obviously otherwise we
would have had more people knocking on
the door to talk to us about it so it's
good to tidy it up and actually make
sure that we cover the effect beside it
so i'm really comfortable with the
recommendations in the report
counselor
with uh just a few little tweaks i'm
actually really happy with it as well
it's something that we have to do and to
bring in that affected is
to me is really important
so and that covers those other those
other buildings that are
that have the um that are beside um one
that is a dangerous one
so i'm happy with what where we've come
to over this okay
thank you councillor duty i think
council lebanese raised the topic that
we weren't overwhelmed with submissions
in fact uh there were really none on
point as such
um
it did appear to be an unusual topic
dangerous affected or in sanitary
buildings policy hardly likely to set
the world on fire with that description
but it is an important
matter nonetheless and it is an
interesting
small area of policy but under the act
we do have to have a policy and we do
have to review it every five years so
having said that i'll now put the motion
all those in favor
i opposed
thank you
we'll now move on to
item five
deliberations
we have the statement of proposal
the
policy with the tract changes plus the
further amendments that have been
discussed previously
and we also have the outcome of the
consultation with the bang the table
reports
so
warren do you wish to
say anything at this point
uh no i think we've had a fairly
uh broad conversation around this and i
accept
the recommendations that have been
proposed changes have been made so i
think with the
bit of fine tuning we'll have something
that will be really useful
right any further discussion from my
colleagues
we we don't actually
have emotion here
but um
i'm just wondering the best way of
getting the policy onto the table with
the amendments
sorry we're going to council on the
7th or 14th of december
right
well if there's no further discussion we
had
a good
go through with the terms of the policy
i'll move that the policy as amended be
referred to council for
adoption
at its
meeting
november december
december meeting is there a second
councilor barney
any further discussion
i'll put the motion all in favor say aye
opposed
carried
well if that's the case um
i'll
thank you for your attendance
including kay
over on the left keeping the records
and declare the meeting closed
thank you very
thank much
bye